The people of Hong Kong are out in the streets.
Hundreds of thousands are demonstrating against
a deeply unpopular bill.
But this is about a whole lot more than a bill.
It’s about the status of Hong Kong
and the power China has over it.
It’s a fight to preserve the freedoms people
have here.
And it all started with a murder.
On February 8, 2018, a young couple, Chan
Tong Kai and Poon Hiu-Wing, went from their
home in Hong Kong to Taiwan for a vacation.
They stayed at the Purple Garden Hotel in
Taipei for nine days.
But on February 17th only one of them returned
to Hong Kong.
There, one month later, Chan confessed to
murdering his girlfriend, who was pregnant
at the time.
But there was a problem.
Hong Kong authorities couldn’t charge him
for murder, because he did it in Taiwan.
And they couldn’t send him back to Taiwan
to be charged,
because Hong Kong and Taiwan don’t have
an extradition agreement.
So in 2019, Hong Kong’s government proposed
one: it would let them transfer suspects to
Taiwan so they could be tried for their crimes.
But the same bill would also allow extradition
to mainland China.
Where there's no fair trial, there's no humane punishment,
and there's completely no separation
of powers.
And that's what sparked these protests.
China and Hong Kong are two very different
places with a very complex political relationship.
And the extradition bill threatens to give
China more power over Hong Kong.
See, Hong Kong is technically a part of China.
But it operates as a semi-autonomous region.
It all began in the late 1800s, when China
lost a series of wars to Britain and ended
up ceding Hong Kong for a period of 99 years.
Hong Kong remained a British colony until
1997, when Britain gave it back to
China, under a special agreement.
It was called “One Country, Two Systems.”
It made Hong Kong a part of China, but it
also said that Hong Kong would retain
"a high degree of autonomy,” as well as democratic
freedoms like the right to vote, freedom of
speech, freedom of the press, of assembly.
And that made Hong Kong very different from
mainland China, which is authoritarian: Citizens
there don’t have the same freedoms.
Its legal system is often used to arrest,
punish, and silence people who speak out against
the state.
But according to the agreement, One Country,
Two Systems wouldn’t last forever.
In 2047, Hong Kong is expected to fully become
a part of China.
The problem is, China isn’t waiting
for the deal to expire.
Under the rule of Chinese leader Xi Jinping,
pro-democracy leaders have already been arrested
in Hong Kong.
And mysterious abductions of booksellers have
created a threat to free speech.
But Hong Kong has been pushing back.
In 2003, half a million Hongkongers successfully
fought legislation that would have punished
speaking out against China.
And in 2014, tens of thousands of protesters
occupied the city for weeks to protest China’s
influence over Hong Kong’s elections.
Now, Hong Kongers are fighting the extradition
bill,
because the bill is widely seen as the next
step in China’s encroachment
on Hong Kong’s autonomy.
The sheer size of these protests shows you
just how much opposition there is to this bill.
But if Hong Kong’s legislature votes on
the bill, it’ll probably pass.
And that’s because of the unique nature
of Hong Kong’s democracy.
For starters, Hong Kong’s people don’t
vote for their leader.
The Chief Executive is selected by
a small committee and approved by China.
And even though they’re the head of the
government, they don’t make the laws.
That happens here.
Like many democracies, Hong Kong has a legislature,
with democratically elected representatives.
It’s called the Legislative Council, or
LegCo, and it has 70 seats.
Within this system, Hong Kong has many political
parties, but they are mostly either pro-democracy
or pro-China.
In every election, Hong Kong’s pro-democracy
and anti-establishment parties have won the
popular vote.
But they occupy less than half of the seats
in the LegCo.
This is because when Hong Kongers vote, they’re
only voting for these 40 of the 70 seats.
The other 30 are chosen by the various business
communities of Hong Kong.
For example, one seat belongs to the finance
industry.
One seat belongs to the medical industry.
One belongs to the insurance industry.
And so on.
Many of these 30 seats are voted on by
corporations.
And because big business has an incentive
to be friendly with China, those seats are
dominated by pro-China political parties.
When Hong Kong was handed over to China in
1997, Hong Kong and China made an agreement
that eventually, all members of the council
would be elected by the people.
But that never happened.
And ever since the handoff, pro-China parties
have controlled the LegCo, despite having
never won more than 50 percent of the popular
vote.
The way it's structured, they want to make
sure that the executive branch
can have easy control over it.
And that would serve Beijing very well indeed.
Within this unique structure, the extradition
bill has created new tensions and fueled anger
among pro-democracy politicians.
And it’s driven hundreds of thousands of
Hong Kongers into the streets.
While this isn’t Hong Kong’s first protest
against China’s influence, it is the biggest.
And many say this time is different, because of the people involved.
Professionals like lawyers and politicians are participating.
Our legal sector staged their biggest ever protest parade.
But it’s young people who are at the forefront,
since they have the most to lose.
They are the first generation born under One
Country Two Systems.
And in 28 years when that arrangement ends,
they’ll be Hong Kong’s professional class.
I won't be around anymore.
It's their future.
It’s their Hong Kong. They have every
right to fight it.
The protests have convinced Hong Kong’s
government to suspend the bill.
But that’s not enough.
Many want the bill withdrawn completely.
That’s because these protests are also part
of a larger fight.
To push back against China's encroachment
now, not just when time’s up.
2047 is on its way.
But it’s not here yet.
And until then,
Hongkongers still have a voice.
History will tell whether we succeed,
but even if we failed,
history would say they did put up a fight and they didn't just take things lying down.
And that's what we're trying to do too.